the European election campaign has
entered the final stretch six candidates
make their pitch for becoming the next
presidents of the European Commission
[Music]
a commission of the people that is what
I want to work for I want to call the
next Commission the commission of a
fresh start of a new era of readiness
openness for optimism for showing to the
world that they can achieve as European
so much together
it's time big companies finally started
paying taxes it's time we introduced the
minimum wage in every member state it is
time we put an end to violence against
women in Europe it is time we put the
climate crisis and sustainability on the
very very top of the list of the next
commission I would like to have European
Commission which respects all its
members regardless whether they are big
or small or whether they are from the
West or from the East I would like to
have European Union which is doing less
but better and which is able to find new
equilibrium between national and
European level the candidates designated
by the major European parties outlined
different approaches but everyone agreed
that Europe must change Europe is the
best place to live today we have
achieved so much that doesn't make
everything good we have work to do to
fight climate change to deal with
technology to create societies build on
the rule of law where you can provide
for yourself that's why I'm here
we need to act but it does leave change
and it does need courage and it does
need a strong force in the European
Parliament that will fight for climate
protection for social Europe and for
democracy not just in words but also in
action
Sasa - hope so leader capacity that
Solidaire dezer avec les Oh Rashida
fondue consulate a militant San Nicola
responsible Sanok Allah says settle hope
will continue a are they form
[Music]
you
[Music]